drg franziska gefallen herr professor
wieder vom robert-koch-institut der
präsident und wir haben heute zu dass
der stressforscher herrn professor
master atli ich noch einen kurzen
hinweis für alle die uns an den
bildschirmen verfolgen dies ist eine
veranstaltung der bundespressekonferenz
und die bundespressekonferenz ist eine
regierungsunabhängige organisation die
dafür sorgt dass journalistinnen und
journalisten gut aus dem bundestag und
über die bundesregierung berichten
können wir gewährleisten dass hier alle
fragen gestellt werden können und zwar
nicht nur von den mitgliedern der
bundespressekonferenz sondern auch von
den ausländischen kollegen die aus
deutschland die aus deutschland
berichten und über deutschland berichten
wir freuen uns immer wenn die
bundesregierung zu uns kommt und hier
uns für unsere fragen zur verfügung
steht und ich danke sehr herzlich den
gebärdendolmetscherin heute zwei
dolmetscherinnen die mir die uns phoenix
sozusagen zur verfügung stellt damit
auch uns alle mitverfolgen können
die darauf angewiesen sind so das thema
ist klar es geht um die bekämpfung des
corona virus und herr minister sie haben
das wort bitte schön was meine damen und
herren so kurz vor ostern das ist uns
wichtig noch einmal zum stand der dinge
mit ihnen ins gespräch zu kommen es ist
die zeit um die entwicklung auch die
positiven entwicklungen der letzten tage
zu kommentieren aber es ist auch die
zeit um zu sagen auch jetzt vor ostern
und den osterfeiertagen wir dürfen jetzt
nicht nachlässig werden
das osterfest steht bevor ein
traditionelles familienfest das höchste
christliche fest dass wir in
gemeinschaft feiern
nur diesmal eben unter ganz anderen
umständen wahrscheinlich einmaligen
umständen in der geschichte deutschlands
ich weiß es fällt vielen schwer zu
ostern auf dem besuch bei der familie
und den freunden zu verzichten
auch mir ganz persönlich fällt es schwer
zu ostern nicht im münsterland meine
eltern besuchen zu können meine
geschwister oder auch die neffen und
nichten um mich schmerzt auch
dass wir an ostern das sich an ostern
nicht in gewohnter weise in den
gottesdienst gehen kann
das geht mir so das geht vielen vielen
anderen millionen bürgerinnen und
bürgern in deutschland so und ich weiß
dass diese starken als einschnitte in
den alltag uns allen viel abverlangt
umso besser ist es dass wir sagen können
die einschnitte in den alltag die wir
seit zwei drei wochen begonnen ja mit
der absage von großveranstaltungen der
schließung von kindergärten und schulen
und anderen erfolgenden maßnahmen
beschlossen haben umsetzen dass diese
maßnahmen wirkung zeigen
an den zahlen die professor wieder
gleich auch noch vorstellen wird sehen
wir die ersten gemeinsamen erfolge wir
haben bei fast 110 1000 infizierten in
deutschland beim robert koch institut
gemeldet
über 50.000 gesundete die zahl der neu
gemeldeten infektionen flacht sich ab
wir haben eher wieder eine lineare
steigerung nicht mehr die dynamischen
steigerung exponentiell wenn wir sie
auch mit dem märz gesehen haben und von
tag zu tag im schnitt eine steigerung
prozentual von vier bis fünf prozent
die deutsche bevölkerung die bürgerinnen
und bürger haben durch ihr umsichtiges
verhalten maßgeblich dazu beigetragen
dass es diese entwicklung geben konnte
und dafür möchte ich ausdrücklich danke
sagen wir lesen daran aber auch ab wie
wichtig es ist weiter konsequent zu
bleiben
denn wenn wir über ostern nachlässig
würden wenn wir wieder den persönlichen
kontakt suchten zu anderen in größeren
gruppen feierten dann gefährdeten wir
die ersten erfolge unserer gemeinsamen
anstrengung etwas sagen zu der frage wie
gut deutschland vorbereitet war oder ist
gut vorbereitet sein heißt nicht alles
schon vorher zu wissen das konnten wir
nicht dafür ist auch zu viel dynamik in
der entwicklung dafür ist so viel neu
und dafür gibt es ja auch eigentlich von
tag zu tag von woche zu woche immer
wieder neue erkenntnisse aber in
angemessener besonnener und
entschiedener weise zu entscheiden
handeln agieren und reagieren zu können
darum geht es und wir sehen bis hier hin
dass das deutsche gesundheitswesen bei
allen problemen die es im alltag gibt
eine starke basis hat wir haben hoch
anerkannte expertinnen und experten an
unseren universitätskliniken
epidemiologen infektiologen virologen
weniger lungenärzte und viele weitere
die international anerkannt sind und
gesellschaft und politik beraten
wir haben mitte märz entschieden
planbare operationen und aufnahmen in
den krankenhäusern zu verschieben und
zusätzliche intensivbetten aufzubauen um
tragische situation wie in anderen
ländern so weit als möglich zu vermeiden
obwohl aktuell über 3000 patienten in
deutschland intensiv medizinisch die
meisten von ihnen auch mit beatmung
behandelt werden sind stand jetzt in
deutschland über 10.000 intensivbetten
frei 40 prozent der intensivbetten in
deutschland sind aktuell frei das ist
nicht zuletzt gelungen weil sie uns
gemeinsam frühzeitig vorbereitet haben
auf das was kommen kann
das macht es uns im übrigen auch möglich
auch das will ich ausdrücklich sagen in
einer zeit wo wir erleben dass das ganze
auch europa unter stress setzt auch
solidarisch zu sein mit unseren nachbarn
in dem wir eben patienten auch aus den
nachbarländern aufgenommen haben und
hier in kliniken in deutschland auf der
intensiv medizin behandeln wir sehen
dass wir hohe test kapazitäten im
deutschen gesundheitswesen haben und
zwar nicht erst jetzt sondern
strukturell schon seit vielen vielen
jahren wir schaffen bis zu 100.000 tests
am tag
auch das ist wichtig um frühzeitig
weiter zu erkennen wie sich die dinge
entwickeln übrigens in den letzten tagen
war eine nicht geringe zahl der testung
die jeden tag durchgeführt wurden auch
in pflegeeinrichtungen nicht zuletzt um
auch dort frühzeitiger noch zu erkennen
wenn es dort infektionen gibt
wir haben ambulante strukturen die mit
170000 einzelpraxen sehr sehr stark sind
es ist der erste schutzwall in dieser
corona epidemie sechs von sieben cupid
patienten werden ambulant behandelt und
es ist gelungen zusammen mit den
ärztinnen und ärzten strukturen
aufzubauen die lust wo die die getrennt
sind dass wir die regelversorgung haben
für diejenigen die als chronisch kranke
natürlich weiterhin
ihren besuch beim arzt brauchen und dass
wir die versorgung von corona
verdachtsfällen und natürlich von kogit
patienten soweit es geht auch davon
trennen können um auch das
infektionsrisiko zu minimieren auch das
ist im system eben mit so vielen die
mithelfen und mit anpacken gut gelungen
in den letzten wochen wir haben wenige
andere länder im übrigen die so viele
reha-einrichtungen reha kliniken haben
wie deutschland und das hilft uns gerade
auch jetzt in dieser phase weil die reha
kliniken in der lage sind auch die akkus
stationären krankenhäuser zu entlasten
oder auch jetzt in der kurzzeitpflege
mit einzuspringen und zu helfen weil
auch dort ja sowohl in den
pflegeeinrichtungen wie in der pflege zu
hause situation entstehen und
entschieden entstehen können die eben
eine alternative dann auch brauchen und
in reha-einrichtungen gelingt genau das
wir haben in deutschland einen
mittelstand und industrie mit
internationalen erfahrungen und
verbindungen die helfen die gerade auch
jetzt helfen bei der persönlichen
schutzausrüstung bei der beschaffung
aber auch mit der bereitschaft in
deutschland zu produzieren
die helfen und geholfen haben auch den
mangel die probleme bei den
desinfektionsmitteln zum beispiel zu
beheben in einer gemeinsamen aktion der
chemischen industrie der
verpackungsindustrie des großhandels
anderer beteiligter auch dort zügig
alternativen zu finden
wir haben ein politisches system auch
mit den entscheidungen des bundestages
und des bundesrates und eine verwaltung
die für das gesundheitswesen flexibel
und zügig entschieden und vieles möglich
gemacht hat auch ein finanzieller
sicherheit in dieser schwierigen zeit
und vor allem haben wir hunderttausende
gut ausgebildete ärztinnen und ärzte
pflegekräfte apotheker mta ist
medizinisch technische angestellte die
mit helfen etwa in den laboren
mittlerweile im dreischichtbetrieb fast
jeden tag der woche und viele viele
andere mehr
die mit anpacken und die nicht home
office machen können nicht heimarbeit
sondern die jeden tag auch vor ort
mithelfen und sie alle leisten
großartige arbeit
auch dafür möchte ich ausdrücklich danke
sagen und ich weiß es ist schön
finanzielle sicherheit und anerkennung
ist noch schöner und auch wichtig und
auch daran arbeiten wir weiter für alle
die im gesundheitswesen tätig sind
vieles davon merken die bürgerinnen und
bürger nicht immer unmittelbar aber sie
spüren schon dass wir bis hierhin
jedenfalls vergleichsweise gut gemeinsam
durch gekommen sind
und abschließend ja wir wollen
schrittweise zurück zur normalität
aber von einem alltag wie wir ihn
kannten vor krone sind wir noch weit
entfernt
nicht alles wird gleich wieder so werden
können wie es war
wir werden weiter in und mit der
pandemie in deutschland leben
deshalb gilt es auch zur wahrheit wir
werden noch über lange strecken über
wochen und monate auf manche
liebgewonnene verzichten müssen
auf festivals auf dem besuch von clubs
oder auf manches volksfest dieser
verzicht tut auch weh dieser verzicht
ist aber auch notwendig um chronisch
kranke oder ältere mitbürgerinnen und
mitbürger zu schützen
ostern wird eine weggabelung sein
bleiben wir auch übers wochenende
konsequent wird die schrittweise
rückkehr zu normalität wahrscheinlicher
werden wir jetzt nachlässig steigt die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass eine
verlängerung der auflagen nötig wird
aber ich bin da zuversichtlich denn wenn
ich etwas gespürt habe in den letzten
wochen dann dass wir als gesellschaft
gerade in dieser krise enger
zusammengerückt sind
lassen sie uns auch weiterhin unter
stress vertrauen
vielen dank herr minister frau dr
vielen dank an meine damen und herren
entspannen hat es schon gesagt wir sind
in einer ausnahme situation wir haben
uns in den letzten drei wochen
diszipliniert verhalten viele
bürgerinnen und bürger haben den ernst
der lage auch für sich ernst genommen
und haben diese nie dagewesenen
situation gut gemeistert auch viele
familien haben das gut gemeistert trotz
aller schwierigkeiten es ist eine
immense herausforderung für unser land
und auch wenn ostern jetzt vor der tür
steht das wetter ist wunderbar
eingesteht dass ein um sich mit freunden
und familie zu treffen so will ich auch
appellieren heute dass die menschen sich
weiter an die regeln halten dass wir
eben nicht nachlassen einfach auch
deshalb weil wir sehen dass was in den
letzten wochen geschafft wurde ist ja
tatsächlich einen beitrag zu einer
positiven entwicklung wir sind mit dem
ziel gestartet diese maßnahmen sind mit
dem anspruch gestartet die verbreitung
einzudämmen
die infektionen gering zu halten und das
ist gelungen
und all das was jetzt gelungen ist es
ein bisschen auch der lohn dafür dass
sich alle so diszipliniert verhalten
haben und jetzt dürfen wir einfach dass
nicht alles aufs spiel setzen es darf
nicht umsonst gewesen sein was in den
letzten wochen auch an anstrengungen und
auch an verzicht geleistet worden ist
von uns allen
und deswegen ist es eben wichtig dass
jede und jeder jetzt seine verantwortung
auch weiter wahrnimmt und sich darüber
klar wird auch diese zeit gut
vorbeigehen sie wird vorbeigehen wir
werden darüber kommen und vielleicht ist
jetzt auch der zeitpunkt um für später
die familienfeiern die partys die freude
darauf zu planen
aber es eben jetzt noch nicht zu machen
es ist wichtig dass wir zusammenhalten
und wir erleben und ich habe heute
vormittag mit den wohlfahrtsverbänden
einer telefonschalte gehabt die mir
berichtet haben aus ihren einrichtungen
aus den vielen vielen gesprächen
telefonaten mit denen die vor ort jeden
tag arbeiten in den sozialen diensten in
der freien wohlfahrtspflege
es ist eine große solidarität da es ist
viel engagement da und auch viel
freiwilligkeit freiwilliges engagement
um in dieser lage dort wo es nötig ist
zu helfen das sehen wir an ganz vielen
stellen und es ist wichtig dass wir
deutlich machen auf allen ebenen bund im
land in den kommunen
dort wo es schwierig ist wo hilfe
gebraucht wird wird auch geholfen das
wird
seht wir sehen es bei uns auf
bundesebene in den hilfe telefonen die
wir zur verfügung stellen ob bei der
nummer gegen kummer für kinder und
jugendliche oder auch beim lesertelefon
gegen gewalt an frauen wir erhalten das
aufrecht wir haben uns mit den
bundesländern darauf verständigt dass
selbstverständlich die kinder und
jugendhilfe ihrer arbeit
aufrechterhalten muss weil kinder und
jugendschutz eben auch
gesundheitsschutzes und dass diese
anlaufstellen und auch kontaktstellen
aufrecht erhalten bleiben müssen und
daran alles gesetzt werden muss wir
sehen dass viele ihre arbeit komplett
umgestellt haben nicht nur home office
sondern eben auch die erreichbarkeit
vielmehr in telefonberatung in online
und video beratung das funktioniert aber
wir sehen auch dass vielfach die
technische ausstattung dafür noch nicht
ganz da sind wir haben uns deshalb jetzt
auch entschieden die frauenhäuser und
frauenberatungsstellen mit zusätzlicher
technischer ausstattung mit geld vom
bund zu unterstützen damit sie diese
dinge die sie dringend brauchen ob in
der schwangerschaftskonfliktberatung
oder auch in der beratung gegen gewalt
an frauen dann auch tatsächlich per
video online chat und telefon auch
tatsächlich machen zu können das halten
wir für sehr wichtig genauso wie die
feststellung dass all diese menschen die
in den hilfe telefon in den
beratungsstellen jetzt für ratsuchende
da sind natürlich systemrelevant sind
systemrelevant sind und damit auch für
die note betreuung ihrer kinder besorgt
sein muss und genau so auch für die
ausstattung mit schutzkleidung das ist
etwas was an uns immer wieder auf
zurückgespiegelt wird die frage
schutzkleidung ausrüstung nicht nur für
krankenhäuser und pflegeheime sondern
natürlich auch in der kinder und
jugendhilfe in der hilfe für menschen
mit behinderung
ich halte das für sehr wichtig dass wir
das auch weiter machen wir haben oft
darüber gesprochen und der beschaffungs
starb hat das ja auch im blick und
arbeitet ja sehr eng mit den ländern auf
dazu zusammen
ich will etwas sagen zu den konkreten
maßnahmen die wir tatsächlich jetzt auch
eingeleitet haben und ich kann ihnen
dazu auch neue zahlen übermitteln
wir haben hier am ersten april genau vor
acht tagen den notfall kinderzuschlag
gestartet für menschen für familien die
jetzt massive einkommenseinbußen haben
die vielleicht vorher gar nicht von den
staatlichen leistungen profitiert haben
weil sie einfach genug geld selbst
verdient haben wir haben viele die sind
jetzt in kurzarbeit oder sie hier können
als selbstständige nicht mehr in dem
sinne weiter arbeiten sie haben massive
einkommenseinbußen und haben vielleicht
kinder und in diesem fall gibt es eben
die möglichkeit den notfall
kinderzuschlag zu beziehen
er ist eine zusatzleistung zum
kindergeld und zum wohngeld und wir
haben ab ersten april diesen notfall
kits geschaltet der ermöglicht dass
nicht die letzten sechs monate
durchschnitts einkommen genommen werden
sondern nur das aktuelle einkommen also
wenn sie im april beantragen das
einkommen von merz und wenn sie dort
eben eine massive einkommenseinbußen
dann wird das entsprechend
berücksichtigt und sie können bis zu 185
euro pro kind zusätzlich zum kindergeld
bekommen
ich kann ihnen mitteilen dass wir in den
ersten acht tagen in denen jetzt der
kids digital online ist und zur
verfügung steht für den notfall kits
wirklich eine große antrags menge hatten
nämlich in acht tagen fast 80.000
anträge die digital eingegangen sind das
heißt es kommt an bei den eltern und ich
will an dieser stelle auch sagen es sind
ganz ganz viele kolleginnen und kollegen
die jetzt in den familienkassen arbeiten
und das alles auch bewältigen und mein
dank geht da auch an unsere kolleginnen
kollegen die in den verwaltungen in der
bundesarbeitsagentur aber auch in den
familienkassen das jetzt machen damit
die familien schnell an ihr geld und an
ihre unterstützung auch kommen und ihren
anspruch wahrnehmen können wir haben
sehr viele freiwillige ich habe das
schon gesagt und unser großer bereich
den wir bei uns im familienministerium
verantworten sind ja die freiwilligen
dienst leistenden die ein jahr entweder
im bundesfreiwilligendienst oder aber
einem freiwilligen sozialen oder
ökologischen jahr arbeiten das sind
knapp 100000 menschen und wir sehen dass
von denen schon über 25.000 auch in
krankenhäusern pflegeeinrichtungen oder
rettungsstellen arbeiten da die machen
natürlich weiter ihre arbeit aber es
gibt einige die jetzt nicht ihren dienst
tun können weil sie
entsprechend in einrichtungen sonst
tätig sind in denen die jetzt gerade
geschlossen sind und das bedeutet wir
überlegen welches angebot wir dort
machen können und wir haben uns
entschieden dafür ein angebot zu machen
nämlich eine ausnahmeregelung in kraft
gesetzt dass die jungen menschen die
jetzt nicht ihren regulären dienst
machen können an einem anderen
einsatzort ihre arbeit machen können
wir haben in dieser woche das hilfs
portal www freiwillige helfen jetzt
gestartet wo wir versuchen eben die
freiwilligen dort auch zu vermitteln an
andere einsatzorte und ich will
vielleicht auch noch etwas sagen zu den
international tätigen freiwilligen die
im internationalen
jugendfreiwilligendienst bisher waren
wir hatten über 2500 junge menschen die
in der ganzen welt verteilt ihren dienst
taten wir haben seit dem 16 mehr als
diese jungen menschen zurück geholt und
ich kann ihnen auch dazu die aktuellen
zahlen mitteilen wir sind bei einer zahl
von 2126 die zurückgekehrt sind auch in
zusammenarbeit mit dem auswärtigen amt
das sind 83 prozent die jetzt mit den
rückhol möglichkeiten des auswärtigen
amtes aus der ganzen welt nach hause
geholt worden sind 289 freiwillige also
elf prozent wollen nicht zurück kehren
sie wollen dort bleiben wo sie sind und
6 prozent das sind 155 freiwillige die
warten gerade noch auf ihre rückreise
dass es aber alles organisiert das heißt
in den nächsten tagen werden alle zu
hause sein und das war für uns auch sehr
wichtig dass diese freiwilligen dann
auch weiter ihr taschengeld ihre
versicherung bekommen sowie die die auch
hier in deutschland tätig sind egal ob
sie jetzt ihren einsatz machen können
oder nicht
ich will mich zum abschluss bedanken bei
allen bürgerinnen und bürgern die sich
an die regeln halten bei allen die ihre
arbeit machen in den pflegeeinrichtungen
in den krankenhäusern in den
supermärkten bei der müllabfuhr oder
einfach überall dort wo jetzt nicht
darum ob es möglich ist und ich will
aber auch den danken die im home-office
ihren job machen
im familienministerium sind über 90
prozent der kollegen im
home office und der die arbeit läuft
trotzdem weiter und das ist auch sehr
sehr wichtig ich will mich bedanken
auch ganz ausdrücklich an die vielen
vielen frauen die in den sozialen
berufen arbeiten über 80 prozent
derjenigen die in den sozialen berufen
arbeiten die wir jetzt immer als
systemrelevant herausstellen sind frauen
und wir haben eine debatte auf der einen
seite über prämienzahlung aber auf der
anderen seite und ich will das auch an
dieser stelle nochmal wiederholen es ist
richtig eine debatte zu führen und
schritte zu gehen für die aufwertung
dieser sozialen berufe und ich bin ja
auch senioren ministerin
und ich habe in den letzten tagen er
verfolgt einige vorschläge die es da
gibt für die rückkehr zur normalität in
der wir versuchen wollen schrittweise
auch wieder zu einem normalen alltag
zurückzukehren
ich will ihnen eins sagen aus der sicht
auch des senioren ministeriums ich bin
nicht der meinung dass wir eine zwei
klassen gesellschaft auch machen sollten
zwischen denen die raus dürfen und denen
die drin bleiben müssen ich glaube wir
brauchen dort andere lösungen
wir müssen dafür sorgen dass diejenigen
die besonders ein besonderes risiko
haben auch geschützt sind und dafür
sorgen dass die anderen die natürlich
und das will man auch noch mal sagen
ältere menschen sind mündige bürger und
deswegen ist es wichtig dass wir an
dieser stelle auch an die persönliche
verantwortung appellieren und menschen
nicht grundsätzlich verbieten das haus
zu verlassen deswegen ein gedanke an all
die älteren menschen die jetzt alleine
sind die sehr wohl verantwortungsvoll
sind und die sich auch um andere kümmern
genauso wie die die sie pflegen und in
diesem sinne ich glaube wir werden gut
über diese zeit kommen wir tun alles um
unsere diejenigen die in unserer
verantwortung auch besonders stehen zu
unterstützen und ich hoffe dass wir
jetzt auch die ostertage gut nutzen um
tatsächlich vernünftig zu bleiben die
gesundheit zu schätzen und zu schützen
und sich darauf zu freuen wenn die
freiheit wieder mehr möglich macht
vielen dank vielen dank frau minister
herr prof
das argument tag meine damen und herren
ich kann ihnen die aktuellen zahlen
vermitteln möchte auch sagen dass die
maßnahmen die in den letzten wochen
durchgeführt haben dafür vor
natürlich eine positive wirkung zeigen
und das ist sehr erfreulich
wir sehen die zahlen aus heute neunter
14.00 uhr hatten wir offiziell gemeldet
100 8202 kowitz fälle und insgesamt 2100
sieben todesfälle
das sind 246 mehr als am vortag
und damit haben wir eine gesamt inzidenz
momentan von 130 fällen pro 100.000 die
zahl der genesung hatte minister sparen
bereits mit rund 50.000 genannt ich
möchte sagen dass die zahl der neu
übermittelten fälle
trotz aller maßnahmen noch auf einem
hohen niveau ist am dienstag und am
mittwoch waren die zahlen etwas
niedriger bei um die 4000 etwa fälle pro
tag aber heute haben wir schon wieder
5000 fälle pro tag über mittel bekommen
es ist natürlich dass solche
schwankungen vorkommen aber darum müssen
wir einfach sagen von einer entspannung
kann man noch nicht wirklich ausgehen
die fallzahl und die zahl der gene sind
finden sie ja täglich auf dem dashboard
das auf unserer homepage corona ag.de
einsehbar ist
betrachten wir die fälle in deutschland
wenig genauer dann stellen wir fest dass
die betroffene person mit 49 jahren im
durchschnittsalter sind wir haben männer
und frauen gleichermaßen betroffen und
von rund 82.000 diese 108.000 fälle
liegen uns klinische informationen vor
die häufigsten symptome bleiben
eigentlich unverändert zu den letzten
wochen 50 etwa husten 42% fieber 22%
schnupfen und wir wissen dass von und
verkehr 2 prozent der übermittelten
fälle also essen rund 1900 insgesamt
wissen wir dass sie eine
lungenentzündung auch wirklich
entwickelt haben und für rund 42 82 1000
fälle legen und informationen darüber
vor ob die patienten ins krankenhaus
gekommen sind und bei rund 12.000
wurde insgesamt eine hospitalisierung
übermitteln das heißt also von den
erkrankten sind rund 15 prozent auch
hospitalisiert ein wenig in die
todesfälle reingeschaut
ich sagte ihm dass er zurzeit 2107
offiziell gemeldete todesfälle haben im
zusammenhang mit der kogit 19
erkrankungen dass das eben 246 mehr sind
als gestern und der anteile verstorbenen
beträgt nun insgesamt 1,9 prozent das
hatten wir ja erwartet dass die zahl der
todesfälle und der anteil der
verstorbenen steigt das ist in den
letzten tagen auch kontinuierlich so
gewesen
und das liegt zum einen daran dass wir
immer mehr ausbrüche auch in alters und
pflegeheimen auch in krankenhäusern
haben wo halt besonders empfänglich
gruppen untergebracht sind oder sich
aufhalten
zum anderen sehen wir jetzt auch
generell immer mehr erkrankungsfälle bei
älteren menschen wir hatten ja am anfang
die situation dass er viele junge
menschen erkrankt waren von dem wir
wissen dass das risiko einer schweren
erkrankung leichter ist und die
todesfälle die wir jetzt sehen das
betrifft ja jene menschen die für etwa
ein bis zwei wochen erkrankt sind und
darum gehen wir eben davon aus dass das
auch noch weiter steigt die zahl der der
verstorbenen
zurzeit befinden sich viele fälle in
stationärer behandlung und das müssen
wir immer im auge haben dass wir immer
eine momentane sicht haben und natürlich
entwicklung die zukunft nur bedingt
voraussagen können die personen die
verstorben sind waren im durchschnitt 80
jahre alt und 86 prozent der
verstorbenen waren 70 jahre alt rund 70
jahre und älter und die bislang jüngste
verstorbene person ist 28 jahre alt und
lebt einen vorerkrankungen das sind die
schnöden zahlen die ich ihnen immer
vorstellen die lage-einschätzung die
aktuelle lage einschätzung ich möchte
noch einen zweiten punkt heute benennen
und zwar was tun wir neben den ganzen
informationen die wir eruieren und den
forschungsarbeiten auch den den weiteren
digitalen möglichkeiten die wir ja in
dieser woche unter anderem auch
erfolgreich gelaunt stauben
für uns ist natürlich eine ganz zentrale
frage zurzeit wie viele menschen in
deutschland haben denn schon eine saas
koch 2 infektion wirklich durchgemacht
vielleicht auch ohne es zu merken wir
wissen ja dass auch ein teil der
infizierten diese infektion gar nicht
wahrnimmt wie viele sind also schon
immun gegen die krankheit eine wichtige
information die wir brauchen auf dauer
das ist wichtig und ist auch richtig
dass einzuschätzen denn wir können zum
einen dann den verlauf der epidemie
wirklich besser beschreiben und genauer
kennenlernen und vor allen dingen ist es
natürlich auch wichtig dass wir die
maßnahmen die wir eingeleitet haben
immer besser bewerten können die wehr
einblicke wie ein das wahre
infektionsgeschehen haben wir haben zwar
die melde fälle die sie ja alle einsehen
können auf unserer website oder die ich
auch vermelde also die fälle die im
labor wirklich bestätigt worden und wir
können daraus auch die anzahl der
gelesenen berechnen schätzen das tun wir
ja auch aber es gibt natürlich eine
dunkelziffer
und ich gehe zwar nicht davon aus dass
die dunkelziffer sehr hoch ist aber
tatsächlich wissen wir ja die dunkelste
von momentan nicht und wir wollen das
robert koch institut aber natürlich alle
menschen in deutschland wollen mehr über
diese dunkelziffer erfahren und darum
planen wir mehrere studien in denen wir
blut von menschen auf antikörper gegen
das saas kurzweiliges und versuchen
warum untersuchen wir antikörper tun
wenn man antikörper im blut gebildet hat
dann war man mit dem satz wir es eben
schon infiziert und davon gehen wir zur
zeit aus aber ich möchte auch noch mal
betonen dass das eben eine neue
krankheit ist von dem wir noch nicht so
genau sagen können wie das wirklich ist
aber wir gehen momentan davon aus dass
sie natürlich immun sind
wie lange sie immun sind ist noch nicht
bekannt solche antikörper test sind seit
kurzem verfügbar
es gibt eine reihe von tests aber die
qualitätsparameter der testfahrten stark
wir haben drei ansätze momentan im kopf
die wir durchführen wollen also
sogenannte serologische studien zum
einen untersuchen wir das blut von
blutspendern aus ganz deutschland zum
zweiten untersuchen wir das blut von
menschen die in bestimmten co at 19
ausbruchs gebieten leben und zum dritten
untersuchen wir das blut von einer
bundesweit repräsentativen
steven stichprobe also von menschen aus
ganz deutschland
wir arbeiten hier zusammen mit anderen
einrichtungen wissenschaftlern zum
beispiel mit professor drosten institut
der virologie in der charité oder auch
professor pause vom helmholtz zentrum
für infektionsforschung in braunschweig
und selbstverständlich werden in der
zukunft noch weitere kolleginnen und
kollegen dazu kommen denn die mehr
sachverstand uns zur verfügung steht
desto besser
trotz dieser einzelnen studien
vorgestellt nur ganz kurz die erste
studie serologische untersuchung an
blutspendern in deutschland hier
arbeiten wir mit den blutspendediensten
zusammen alle 14 tage sollen hier bis zu
5000 proben untersucht werden
das ist wichtig weil wir auch im
zeitlichen verlauf brauchen eine
einmalige studie zu einem bestimmten
zeitpunkt ist natürlich auch wieder nur
ein einblick zu diesem zeitpunkt in das
geschehen
aufgrund dieser studie lassen sich also
rückschlüsse auf die verbreitung von co
at 19 in deutschland ziehen und das wird
voraussichtlich in der kommenden woche
starten und die proben sollen dann
bereitgestellt werden so dass wir die
ersten ergebnisse im mai erwarten die
zweite studie in ausbruchs gebieten in
deutschland
wir werden vier orte auswählen die
schwer von kogit 19 betroffen waren
die auswahl ist noch nicht endgültig
geschehen aber das wird in den nächsten
tagen der fall sein
und hier wird pro ort das blut von ca
2000 menschen immer wieder auf
antikörper untersucht das ist also dann
eine repräsentative stichprobe die er
war mehrfach durchgeführt werden muss um
die dynamik einzuschätzen und natürlich
befragen wir die menschen nach symptomen
lebensumständen risikofaktoren und auch
ihrem gesundheitsverhalten und diese
studie wird mit der april beginnen und
auch hier erwarten wir die ersten
ergebnisse im mai und die dritte studie
die wir durchführen ist eine sehr
anspruchsvolle studie
diese bevölkerungsrepräsentativen studie
sie ist ähnlich aufgebaut wie die studie
in den ausguss gebieten aber hier eben
repräsentativ für ganz deutschland
insofern natürlich deutlich umfänglicher
ihr werden etwa 15.000 teilnehmer 150
regionen untersucht
wir führen solche untersuchungen
geöffnet und dann studien zu kindern zum
beispiel jugendliche können kinder und
jugendliche gesundheit in deutschland
durch das heißt ja ja viel erfahrung und
diese dritte studie sie startet deshalb
später sie ist anspruchsvoller sie
startet im mai was ist das ziel dieser
studien
wir möchten wissen wie viele menschen in
deutschland immun sind
wir möchten wissen wie hoch ist der
anteil der symptomatischen fälle also
der anteil von den menschen die
infiziert wurden es aber gar nicht
gemerkt haben
und natürlich müssen wir auch dauer auch
eine einschätzung davon haben wie die
menschen wie viele menschen in
deutschland wirklich auch gestorben sind
an der infektion also wie hoch die
richtig die letalität ist also die
sterberate herzlichen dank für die
aufmerksamkeit
vielen dank herr professor villa und
jetzt geht es dort noch mal auf die
andere seite an ein professor athlet und
es geht um das thema stressforschung ja
vielen dank meine damen und herren wir
erleben gerade viel verunsicherung bei
den menschen und ängste
unterschiedlicher art selber zu
erkranken oder angst dass es angehörige
erwischt und gravierende existenzsorgen
kommen dazu und die enorme präsenz des
themas befeuert diese angstgefühle
nämlich vor allen dingen da auch dann
wenn man sich dem thema gar nicht mehr
entziehen kann und dazu kommt jetzt auch
oft noch ein gefühl von ungeduld und
klar ist unser alltag hat sich mit der
pandemie und den beschränkungen im
prinzip über nacht radikal verändert
unser arbeitsleben unser privates und
soziales leben und das macht stress
wirklich durchleben gerade daher nicht
nur eine pandemie muss man sagen sondern
auch eine psychologische krise und
für viele von uns gehen die bewährten
strategien zur stressbewältigung gerade
nicht freunde und familie interessen
sport so wie wir es gewohnt sind
kulturveranstaltungen und vieles mehr
oder dass wir uns auch einfach mal in
den arm nehmen können
und ausgerechnet das was uns stress und
belastung nimmt das uns tröstet das geht
eben gerade jetzt nicht dazu kommt wir
müssen sehr viel mehr zeit mit anderen
auf einem raum verbringen und das alles
wird auch ein risiko für konflikte wir
müssen uns oftmals ungewohnten aufgaben
widmen wie dem homeschooling und dann
mangelt es oftmals dabei an der
notwendigen voraussetzungen wie ein
ruhiger arbeitsplatz oder genügend
rechner
damit geht das kind versorgt ist und das
nat zusätzlich an die nerven
jetzt steht ostern vor der tür
normalerweise verbringen wir das viel
zeit mit freunden und familie
man besucht sich gegenseitig und
unternimmt etwas gemeinsam genießt den
frühling und diesmal geht das nicht und
das kann frustrieren
als psychiater sage ich das wichtigste
ist dass wir uns eingestehen dass es
völlig normal ist dass uns das traurig
macht vielleicht auch wut oder ärger auf
kommt oder wie schon erwähnt angst und
dann kann es helfen darüber zu sprechen
mit angehörigen mit freunden oder mit
kollegen und oftmals hilft es dann auch
zu sehen wenn andere vielleicht eine
besondere haltung einnehmen oder mehr
akzeptanz an den tag legen können in der
psychotherapie spricht man von
perspektivwechsel und auch ein kreativer
umgang mit der situation kann dazu
führen dass es trotzdem schöne
wenngleich etwas andere russland werden
videokonferenzen mit der familie oder
freunden zum beispiel um ein gemeinsames
daher bemalt gemeinsam ist oder sich
einfach mal unterhält
wir sind soziale wesen und menschliche
nähe ist ein psychologisches
grundbedürfnis und dass wir uns jetzt
gerade physisch aus dem weg gehen sollen
entspricht uns nicht und daher jetzt
gerade an ostern soll man und kann man
besonders viel kommunizieren über
telefon
über digitale medien usw auch alte
freundschaften reaktivieren
so gut wie jeder ist gerade dankbar für
soziale kontakte das ist zumindest meine
erfahrung wir sind alle emotional
bedürftiger als zu normalzeiten und
allen hilft verbundenheit und wenn ich
das noch zufügen darf es hilft gerade
über die ostertage auch sich mal eine
corona freie zeit zu verordnen weil
einen halben tag lang sich in etwas
anderes vertiefen in musik ein buch ein
film oder ein gespräch ohne über corona
zu reden so kann man emotional and
listen vermerkt dass zu hause die
stimmung kippt und konflikte entstehen
kann bewusst versuchen sich in
kompromissbereitschaft zu üben nicht auf
dem eigenen standpunkt zu haben und man
sollte ein konflikt auch nicht dann
austragen wenn man sich besonders ärgert
sondern warten bis die anspannung
abgeflaut ist man kann sich auch
vornehmen bei konflikten bewusst
nachzugeben
und wenn die fällen tatsächlich mal hoch
schlagen sollte man sich lieber
zurückziehen den raum auch mal verlassen
statt die auseinandersetzung zu
eskalieren
wenn ich sage die situation macht stress
dann muss ich auch noch dazu erklären
dass stress zunächst mal etwas ganz
normales ist stress wird aber dann zur
gesundheitsbelastung wenn er chronisch
wird und wenn wir ihn subjektiv als
unbeeinflussbare erleben und das
bedeutet wie gut wir jetzt den stress
ertragen hängt von einigen wesentlichen
faktoren ab drei punkte die ich
aufzählen möchte erstens es hilft wenn
ein ende der stress phase in sicht ist
land in sicht ist unsere psyche leidet
bei dauerbelastung ohne aussicht auf
entlastung
daraus folgt wir müssen uns immer wieder
klarmachen dass dies ein vorübergehender
zustand ist so wird es keinesfalls
bleiben und dazu hilft es wenn wir
übrigens auch nicht vergessen auch mal
über die zeit nach corona zu sprechen
zweitens wir brauchen die gewissheit
unsere situation irgendwie auch bei
einflüssen zu können als menschen wie
psychiater und stress forscher nennen
das selbstwirksamkeit erfahrung das
senkt das stresslevel und das gefühl von
angst
wer hingegen die annahme hat hilflos
einer situation ausgeliefert zu sein ist
stress erleben in hohem maße
ausgeliefert daraus folgt wir müssen uns
klarmachen dass wir gerade zusammen eine
menge tun und dass das was wir tun auch
wirklich hilft wir sind der situation
nicht heillos ausgeliefert die
verdopplung zahlen gehen langsam runter
wird der beteiligung uns gerade alle an
einem gigantischen präventionsprojekt
und das zeigt wirkung jede beschränkung
die jeder einzelne gerade hinnimmt
verhindert dass sich mehrere menschen
heute infizieren
dritter punkt wir brauchen hoffnung
hoffnung ist echte währung für die
psyche hoffnung ist die entscheidende
psychologische quelle für motivation und
hoffnung schafft emotionale kraft das
was wir psychiater als resilienz
bezeichnen und für hoffnung sorgt wenn
wir auch in jetzt gerade in dieser zeit
die erfolgsgeschichten sehen dass wir
die in unserer kommunikation auch
deutlich machen dass wir sehen dass die
geschwindigkeit der neuansteckungen
sinkt das wir sehen dass menschen auch
wieder gesund werden das haben wir
gehört und dass wir uns auf die
mitmenschlichkeit um uns herum verlassen
können und dass wir sicher sein können
dass wir es gemeinsam schaffen können
und besonders deutlich will ich
abschließend sagen die strukturen der
psychiatrisch psychotherapeutischen
versorgung sind da wenn mal die ängste
überhandnehmen oder der koma oder
konflikte zu hause die strukturen sind
da und sie sind intakt unsere kliniken
unsere rettungsstellen mit psychiaterin
und psychiatern rund um die uhr
das psychosoziale hilfe netz in den
gemeinden und kommunen den notfall
telefone des kinder und jugendschutzes
die krisen dienste die telefonseelsorge
die alte anlaufstelle nach häuslicher
gewalt wir alle sind da
und unsere türen sind weit offen vielen
dank vielen dank herr professor athen
jetzt habe ich schon einige fragen die
von kollegen und kolleginnen hier aus
dem saal kommen und auch einige fragen
die von den kolleginnen und kollegen
kommen die uns jetzt zu gucken und die
mitglieder der uns einspielen können
die erste frage haben sie bitte der
minister kennen sie so gut aus da kann
die fragen auch beantworten
aber es gibt einfache maßzahlen die wir
natürlich im kopf haben also anzahl neu
infizierte pro tag an eine bestimmte
mathematische größe mit der wir ein
dynamisches geschehen beschreiben das
ist diese r 0 zahl also wieviel
infizierte stecken einen anderen
infizierten an die zahl der positiven
testungen das ist ein wichtiger punkt
also wie viel profil hoch ist der
prozentzahl von bestimmten testung es
gibt also eine menge messzahlen die wir
uns kontinuierlich anschauen und daraus
dass das geschehen einfach einschätzen
können und das tun wir weiterhin und wir
werden die sind diese zahlen halt
auswerten und sehen wie der trend ist
vielleicht einfach auch ergänzen wir
haben in den letzten tagen gesehen dass
wir eher eine lineare entwicklung
hineingekommen sind den wir vorher mitte
märz geben exponentielles wachstum sein
und wenn es uns gelingt gemeinsam als
wären sie das genannte
gesamtgesellschaftlichen präventions-
ansatz sozusagen gemeinsam das
präventionsprojekt als gesellschaft wenn
es uns gelingt gemeinsam
so wurde in absoluten zahlen wie in der
in der entwicklung als lineare
entwicklung das jetzt weiter zu tragen
dann ist das ein ganz ganz wichtiges
faktum ganz ganz wichtiger punkt war
natürlich die frage der absoluten zahl
der neuinfizierten ja mit einer
zeitlichen verzögerung von zehn bis
zwanzig tagen danach erfolgen hat für
das gesundheitswesen
weil eben das haben wir gerade gehört
ein bestimmter anteil 12 bis 15 prozent
klinische betreuung behandlung braucht
und an dann darf und ein bestimmter
anteil intensiv medizin und
beratungskapazitäten so und deswegen ist
dieser entwicklung der letzten tage wenn
sich das fort schreibt ein ganz ganz
wichtiger punkt die frage wie viele
andere steckt jemand an der infiziert
ist wir hatten dieses berühmte er das
war schon richtung 567 unterwegs also
einer steckt 567 andere an wir sind
jetzt bei einer steckt in etwa noch
einen weiteren an das macht natürlich
auch qualitativen großen unterschied
und die frage jetzt gerade bei ostern
ich meinen gestern abend in baden
württemberg gestern nachmittag 28 grad
glaube ich also das ist jetzt schon sie
alle jetzt auch ein gesellschaftliches
gesamt experiment einen solchen feiertag
ein solches wochenende auf all das zu
verzichten oder vieles von dem was
eigentlich eben liebgewonnen zu ostern
dazu gehört aber gerade die dinge und
sie haben darauf hingewiesen die uns als
menschen ein bedürfnis sind auch nahe zu
sein persönlich nahe zu sein gerade an
so einem feiertag freunden verwandten im
park zu setzen und anderes mehr
die gehen eben nicht so wie sonst und
das ist sehr sehr wichtig dass eben über
so ein feiertag wie ostern wo wir
eigentlich viel persönliche nähe haben
damit aber eben auch viel
infektionsrisiko jetzt gemeinsam das
durch tragen dieses risiko nicht
entstehen zu lassen dass das ist im
grunde der große
messzahl sozusagen die sich nachher
wieder schlecht in der zahl der
infizierten aber die wir im zweifel auch
im alltag schon nicht im alltag im
straßenbild so ist besser formuliert
sehen wir in den nächsten tagen das
heißt übrigens nicht dass man nicht vor
die tür darf und dass auch mal zu sagen
natürlich kann man spazieren gehen aber
entscheidend ist spazieren zu gehen mit
denen mit dem man eben selben haushalt
lebt und nicht mit anderen bald an das
infektionsrisiko eben tatsächlich wieder
wieder steigt aber sie spazieren zu
gehen mit dem partner der partnerin den
kindern der familie ist ja bei dem
wetter erstens schön und zweitens sogar
gesund ich meine ist ja ist ja gut
entscheidend ist eben wie und nicht
gruppen und nicht im park zu sitzen
zusammen und anderes mehr
wenn wir das zusammen über dieses große
für uns als gesellschaft wichtige fest
durch tragen dann macht das eben ein
unterschied so dann geht's weiter mit
frau laut welche frage war noch offen
sagen wir haben natürlich familien die
besonders in einer schwierigen situation
auch schon vor der krise waren und diese
sozial benachteiligten familien da kann
man sagen das ist etwa bei 20 prozent
der familien der fall dass dort in
irgendeiner form besondere soziale
belastungen da sind die sind natürlich
jetzt noch mal verstärkt durch das nicht
offen seien von kindergärten und schulen
aber auch durch das beengte den ganzen
tag beieinander sein und für uns ist
gerade deswegen so wichtig deshalb haben
wir auch mit den bundesländern mit den
jugend und familien mit ist dann ganz
klar die leitlinie vereinbart dass alles
was kinder und jugendliche ist auch
aufrecht erhalten bleibt nicht nur die
hilfs telefone sondern auch tatsächlich
die dienste der sonstigen kinder und
jugendliche für das sind systemrelevante
bereiche die müssen aufrechterhalten
bleiben
und die werden auch aufrechterhalten und
natürlich auch noch mal die ganz klare
ansage
es ist auch nicht verboten mit den
kindern raus und spazieren zu gehen das
kann man bei allen familien sehen dass
das natürlich gut ist und dass man da
auch der sozialen konfliktsituation zu
hause ein stückweit entgeht nur eben mit
den beschränkungen die der
gesundheitsminister auch gerade
ausgeführt hat also es ist kein zwang
dass kinder drin bleiben müssen den
ganzen tag das ist das schlechteste was
man machen kann im moment aber eben
verantwortungsvoll und wir versuchen
eben über nicht nur die hilfe telefon
sondern auch neue mittel der digitalen
beschulung der frage wie können auch
diese familien erreicht werden
auch von der kinder- und jugendhilfe
dass wir das eben unterstützen
das halte ich für sehr wichtig man muss
noch mal bewerten wenn jetzt in der
nächsten woche wird ja darüber
gesprochen werden wie das mitglieder und
schulschließungen weitergeht
die haben sehr viele rückmeldungen im
ministerium von familien die natürlich
diese frage brennend interessiert machen
die schulen und kitas wieder auf jahren
ein werden auch von vielen kindern die
rückmeldung dass sie sich wünschen dass
sie wieder in die schule gehen können
dass sie ihre freunde wiedertreffen
können und da ist natürlich ganz viel
hoffnung
man muss aber gucken wirklich was es
verantwortungsvoll und in welchen
schritten kann so etwas auch gemacht
werden
insofern müssen wir auch noch mal dann
die lage neu bewerten wenn man weiß wie
lange es jetzt dauert ob man nochmal
andere formen findet für kinder die
wirklich in einer sehr schwierigen
häuslichen situation sind das machen wir
im moment über die kinder- und
jugendhilfe und die notfallseelsorge
dies gibt an der stelle ich will auch
noch mal darauf hinweisen der
unabhängige beauftragte für fragen
sexuellen kindesmissbrauchs hat ja auch
eine website gestartet kein kind alleine
lassen de das finde ich sehr wichtig ich
begrüße das sehr dass wir also gerade in
den fällen wo wir auch von häuslicher
gewalt gegen kinder sprechen wo wir von
sexuellen missbrauch gegen kinder
springen wo kinder sich im moment eben
nicht in kita und schule irgendwie hilfe
holen können dass wir gerade da eben
auch sagen dass es muss eine möglichkeit
geben für diese kinder auch
andere wege der hilfe zu finden und
deshalb war ich heute auch im live chat
mit den berater mit einer beraterin der
nummer gegen kummer wir versuchen das
jetzt wirklich sehr stark nach vorne zu
bringen haben auch die zeiten
ausgeweitet und die beratung dort
ausgeweitet damit kinder und jugendliche
die in so einer schwierigen häuslichen
lage sind eben auch noch mal speziell
zusätzliche unterstützung bekommen wenn
ich mir noch mal kurz sagen ich habe
anfangs versprochen dass in der
bundespressekonferenz alle fragen
beantwortet werden ich habe jetzt hier
15 fragen und minimum auf meinem zettel
wir müssen uns ein bisschen sozusagen
konzentrieren in der länge der fragen
und antworten damit würde auch durch
gruppen vorlage das wort
er voller endlich passt ihr die letzte
teil dann schon ein bisschen auch zu der
antwort die ich eigentlich geben wollte
weil mein eindruck ist nichts das ist
irgendwie eine einhellige ein förmige
debatte in deutschland gäbe und auch
nicht in der frage wie schon bei der app
ideologien ja nicht wie wir leben und es
auch das auch richtig sowie seine freie
plurale gesellschaft und unsere stärke
als gesellschaft nicht mehr genau darin
dass wir debatten offen führen auch als
repräsentatives als parlamentarisches
als demokratisches system und ich erlebe
und wir alle erleben doch jeden tag dass
diese debatte stattfindet sie findet
statt in der familie
sie findet statt am telefon im digitalen
und sie findet statt in den medien und
sie findet auch statt von sehr christian
lindner und andere genannt in der
politik und das ist auch richtig
genauso wichtig ist es aber eben auch
dass wir auch seitens der
bundesregierung derjenigen die
politische verantwortung tragen aber
auch klar sind in unserer kommunikation
der teil ist eben auch wichtig in der in
der fall von verlässlichkeit und der
frage was wir warum wann machen und da
geht ja beides zusammen was auch herr
professor hat nie gesagt hat das eine
ist doch akzeptanz für maßnahmen für
einschränkungen entsteht doch dann wenn
mit ihnen auch eine perspektive
verbunden ist so und deswegen können die
debatten für mich jedenfalls zusammen
wir haben einschränkungen in die
grundfreiheiten der bürgerinnen und
bürger so stark wie noch nie in der
geschichte der bundesrepublik mit einer
sehr hohen akzeptanz wie heute wieder
einige umfang gezeigt haben dass viele
bürgerinnen und bürger auch sagen sie
finden das richtig weil wir eben auch
öffentlich haben gut erklären können
warum wir tun was wir tun und
gleichzeitig gehört dazu natürlich auch
dass man weiß warum man es tut und dass
wenn jetzt dinge sich entwickeln daraus
eine perspektive erwächst
und das sind kann ich übrigens mit dem
begriff des exits
habe ich immer so mein problem weil ex
suggeriert alles ist von einem tag auf
den anderen wieder so wie vorher
alles ist zuende ausgang und das wird ja
nicht sondern es geht wenn dann um eine
schrittweise rückkehr in den in die
normalität in den alltag bestimmte dinge
werden nimmt deutlich länger darauf
verzichten müssen als auf andere ich
habe bestimmte verhaltensweisen gerade
schon angedeutet also die frage wie man
sich täglich grüßt welchen abstand man
voneinander hält bestimmte dinge werden
wir länger darauf verzichten müssen als
auf andere
und dass das geht dann eben auch für die
frage welche maßnahmen wie das wenn wir
nächste woche dann besprechen ob und wie
da umgesetzt werden aber ich habe nicht
den eindruck
ich kann mir gar nicht vorstellen dass
christian lindner den hat das ist
darüber gar keine debatte geht in
unserer gesellschaft leicht ich kann ja
noch ganz kurzes ergänzen es gibt eine
reihe von studien natürlich tauschen wir
diese studienergebnisse aus das ist ja
der entscheidende punkt die transparenz
der informationen
denn das ist wichtig auch die
studienprotokolle aus denn das sind
immer momentaufnahmen und ist halt sehr
wichtig dass immer einzuschätzen
je nachdem zu welchem zeitpunkt sie eine
bestimmte untersuchung machen haben sie
hat bestimmte ergebnisse machen sie
dieselbe studie
zwei wochen später sind die ergebnisse
anders und das entscheidende ist dass
wir die studienprotokolle austauschen
und miteinander anpassen um gegenseitig
uns zu verstehen und daraus den
bestmöglichen maßnahmen abzuleiten
das sind wissenschaftlich guter prozess
und die das besonders schöne an der zeit
in der wir jetzt leben ist eben dass die
wissenschaftler ihre ergebnisse sehr
schnell der gemeinschaft also nicht nur
der wissenschaftlichen gemeinschaft
sondern eben damit ja auch unserem
ganzen land zur verfügung stellen das
ist transparent
das ist konsequent und es führt dazu
dass man in die diskussion kommt mit dem
wir die maßnahmen die man daraus
ableiten kann auch wirklich gut
evaluieren kann also dieser austausch
ist in einer zeit
so schnell wie wir die normalerweise in
der wissenschaft nicht erleben wo leute
eigentlich publizieren er ist ihre daten
was teilweise wochen dauert das ist eine
tolle entwicklung und seien sie
versichert dass wir alle diese studie so
gut wie möglich natürlich untereinander
austauschen weil das thema ausstieg
jetzt hier schon mehrfach gefallen ist
möchte ich jetzt drei fragen
zusammenfassen die von den kollegen
kommen die uns zu schauen ist einmal der
kollege sascha meyer von dpa der an sie
herr minister sparen die frage stellt
sie hatten bis bis spätestens ostern so
zitiert er sie ein konzept für
ausstiegsszenarien aussicht gestellt
liegt das schon vor ist es eine maßgabe
ein späteres zurücknehmen von
lockerungen zu vermeiden fragt er dann
fragt der kollegen vom zdf auch sie herr
minister sparen erhalten sie bei der
lockerung ein zitat tassen das vorgehen
für möglich wie es der ethikrat
vorgeschlagen hat also nach versuch und
irrtum manche lockerung auch wieder
zurückzunehmen wenn nötig und der
kollege cent ivanyi von amd fragt auch
sie ist es vorstellbar dass man die
beschränkungen regional differenziert
aufhebt also zunächst nur in kommunen
die niedrige fallzahlen haben und alle
danke auch das alles noch kurz das doch
was ist also zum einen die frage herr
meier das ist ja genau die debatte auch
zu konzepten und dem was zusammenzufügen
ist die ja stattfindet es gibt ja die
unterschiedlichsten vorschläge wie ich
habe immer seitens des gesundheitswesens
die frage was ist konzeptionell
notwendig für die weiteren schritte ist
die frage der test kapazität die frage
der belastbarkeit und das ist ja das was
ich gerade dargestellt habe auch der
intensivmedizin der kapazitäten die wir
da haben es ist die frage der
organisation im gesundheitswesen in der
trennung der verhandlungs behandlungs
strenge sozusagen von nicht kroner
patienten und
kroner patienten es ist die frage der
möglichkeit von therapieoptionen und
studien studien und dann ist es vor
allem die lage wie wir sie tatsächlich
dann auch im land messen bei
infektionszahlen anderen anderem mehr
und das fließt natürlich konzeptionell
ein
auch in die weiteren beratungen der
bundesregierung und dann mit den
ministerpräsidenten und den
bundesländern dann in der nächsten woche
die frage nach dem tastenden vorgehen
zwei maschinen zu sagen zwei
verschiedenen nuancen ich habe gerade
von einem schrittweise vorgehen
gesprochen wo aus meiner sicht
jedenfalls wäre er darüber reden welche
möglichen veränderungen kann man zurück
in die normalität machen in einem ersten
schritt dann wenn wir es noch mal sagen
dann wenn wir gemeinsam über ostern das
jetzt durchhalten
das ist schon wichtig das ist dieses
kommunikative vor dem wir stehen
wir können dann darüber reden wenn und
nicht schon zu ostern beginnen damit es
ist wichtig dass da nicht der eindruck
entsteht schrittweise zurückkehren in
die normalität ich finde sogar besser
den ansatz der schrittweisen rückkehr
als das tasten wenn das tasten der hat
natürlich kann es notwendig werden aber
zu sagen wir starten erst mal und
notfalls gehen wir wieder zurück um
schränken wieder ein
das kann man als konzept auch haben
haben einige länder auch führt aber
glaube ich nicht zu mehr vertrauen
verlässlichkeit von entscheidungen
sondern lieber in schritten und und und
und und paketen von maßnahmen die dinge
tun und dann immer eine zeit lang
schauen welche folgen hat das in dem was
wir auf messen im infektionsgeschehen im
land und in den behandlungskapazitäten
als erst mal mutig voran und nachher
wieder zurück zu müssen
das sind zwei verschiedene ansätze und
ich glaube der letztere ansatz kann auf
lange auf auf eine sicht hin auch mehr
vertrauen dann und verlässlichkeit
tatsächlich auch kosten und das dritte
ist herr cent ivanyi die frage von
regionalen unterschieden wir haben
riesen unterschiede wenn sie sich
anschauen
die zahl der infizierten pro 100000
einwohner
den bock vorpommern baden württemberg
sehen sie in einen sehr großen
unterschied zwischen den bundesländern
in deutschland
und das vier bis fünffache er ist
richtig im kopf hatte posser villa und
das lässt die debatte ein gut verstehen
dass es in jedem fall aber braucht ist
das wenn wir an bestimmten städten oder
landkreisen wieder ein stärkeres
infektionsgeschehen haben dass man dann
sehr stark auch regional wird stärker
maßnahmen ergreifen müssen deswegen ist
das testen das zielgerichtete testen so
richtig und das kontakt nach verfolgen
so wichtig das ist ein teil der debatte
haben heute noch gar nicht gehabt eine
voraussetzung für alles was kommt ist
dass wir in der lage sind und bleiben
dann wenn jemand positiv getestet ist
infiziert es mit kroner wir sehr sehr
schnell alle kontakte in der letzten
tage identifizieren und auch isolieren
können das ist ein rezept weltweit das
voraussetzung ist auch für alles weitere
und das kann man händisch machen oder
digital auch die debatte gibt es ja gut
vielen dank jetzt geht's dahin weiter
das genau ist nicht gehalten der sorge
haben dass wir jetzt erstmal die
produzierten ändern
wir sind im kontakt mit den
gleichstellungsministerin und ministern
der länder aber auch mit den
praktikerinnen aus den frauenhäusern und
frauenberatungsstellen werken gerade
gestern dazu eine seite um auch mal
aktuell ein bisschen zu hören was es in
der praxis los wir bekommen die
rückmeldung dass an den zahlen man nicht
erkennt dass wir jetzt eine signifikante
steigerung haben aber das vermutet wird
von den experten experten dass etwas
eintritt weil es häufig in so einer
situation auch in anderen ländern schon
eingetreten ist dass wir eine ein
verzögertes medef erhalten haben hier an
dieser stelle das bedeutet dass viele
frauen die jetzt zu hause sind natürlich
häufig auch den gewalttätigen partner
mit in der wohnung haben einfach
schlicht nicht die möglichkeit haben so
bei einem hilfe telefon anzurufen wie
das normalerweise wäre wenn der partner
tagsüber zur arbeit geht das ist ja bei
vielen gerade nicht gegeben und deswegen
ist natürlich auch die möglichkeit sich
hilfe zu holen eingeweiht vorfall zu
melden
gerade eingeschränkt und es sind auch
andere krisenbedingte schwierigkeiten da
die dann auch vielleicht betroffene
davon abhalten sich zu melden
es ist so dass zusätzlich auch die
frauenhaus kapazitäten teilweise nicht
voll fahren können weil
quarantänemaßnahmen da sind weil auch
dort personal nur eingeschränkt da es
entweder weil menschen selber erkrankt
sind oder sie sich um ihre
kinderbetreuung kümmern müssen deshalb
ist für uns so wichtig dass wir auch
ganz stark an die länder noch mal ab wie
viren für die systemrelevanz dieser
berufe das eben die frauen die gerade
und frauenhaus dringend gebraucht werden
nicht deshalb nicht da sind weil sie
ihre kinder nicht betreuen können
also das sehen wir alles und wir sind
jetzt in einer situation wo es sehr
wichtig ist sich vorzubereiten auf
dieses verzögerte meldeverhalten und
auch in einer situation in der wir
gemeinsam mit unseren partnern wäre mir
eine initiative gegründet stärker als
geweihter gibt es auch ein portal
stärker als gewaltige dann wird die
großen organisationen in deutschland
würden sie sich mit häuslicher gewalt
beschäftigen dass wir auch andere wege
finden um besonders frauen zu
ermöglichen die nicht von zu hause aus
jetzt anrufen können die vielleicht auch
nicht von ihrem eigenen handy anrufen
können entweder weil die karte lehrers
oder weil es kontrolliert wird vom dass
sie andere orte finden und da sind wir
im gespräch wir haben kontakt zu
verschiedenen da würde ich einfach in
der nächsten woche wahrscheinlich wenn
wir da ein bisschen konkreter was zu
sagen können ob sie noch mal informieren
aber es geht jetzt darum dass wir die
kapazitäten hochfahren wenn es nötig ist
das haben viele bundesländer auch schon
gemacht mit der möglichkeit wohnung
anzumieten oder akut anzumieten um
frauen und dazu bringen sollte es nötig
sein aber auch eben das personal dann
vorzuhalten und in die lage zu versetzen
dort zu helfen
also wir sehen jetzt noch nicht einen
signifikanten anstieg wir gehen aber
davon aus wenn die krise sich etwas
entspannt dass wir dann auch ein
erhöhtes meldeverhalten haben dann geht
es weiter mit den login
[Musik]
da kann ich gleich noch eine nachfrage
hier nachschieben aus von den kollegen
von außerhalb andreas reuter von ard
hörfunk fragt nach dem stand der
vorbereitungen bei der treff ist racing
apps trieben sie an dass es für
deutschland eine quasi offizielle app
gibt die das robert-koch-institut koch
institut empfiehlt und an herrn minister
sparen inwieweit ist die einführung und
akzeptanz der tracing relevant für art
und umfang von möglichen erleichterungen
bei den kontakt und ausgangs
beschränkungen ja soll ich die erste
frage also die frage stellen kann ich
nicht beantworten dazu sind die die auf
lösungen der informationen die bislang
haben nicht hoch genug
[Musik]
das tut mir leid das kann hier nicht
beantworten sagt zu der app noch was
sagen zu der zu der daten spende app
also dieser zunächst einmal die daten
spende app die ist ein sehr großer
erfolg haben sich bereits 160 tausend
nutzer gemeldet das ist wirklich
überwältigend möchte ich sagen dass das
haben wir so gar nicht erwartet und
trainieren jetzt mal erst diesen
algorithmus und wir werden dann
wahrscheinlich in drei wochen die ersten
karten sehen darum geht es ja wir wollen
ja quasi bestimmte muster sehen an
[Musik]
krankheitszeichen wie sie sich regional
verteilen
wir sind uns völlig bewusst dass dass
das eine große verantwortung ist mit
diesem persönlichen daten umzugehen wir
haben diese app deshalb entwickelt sehr
streng natürlich nach den vorgaben des
datenschutzes auch in enger abstimmung
natürlich mit den
datenschutzbeauftragten auch die
datenschutz und die datensicherheit
experten sind und waren auch weiterhin
sehr in die prüfung von servern und
schnittstellen natürlich mit eingebunden
wir haben das entwickelt wie sie sagen
das zu recht mit einem privaten
technischen dienstleister das ist klar
dass die technisch natürlich bestimmte
qualitäten die wir nicht haben
wir haben eine kommerzielle nutzung
ausgeschlossen
von von lisa von diesen daten und der
dienstleister
er stellt die technologische basis dafür
zur verfügung die verschiedenen
datenformate die verschiedene geräte und
hersteller liefern werden in ein
einheitliches format umgewandelt und das
brauchen wir eben um schließlich
wissenschaftlich auszuwerten
dass die die technologische basis das
ist ein geistiges eigentum der firma und
die nutzung der app ist freiwillig
natürlich auch gerade das heißt wir
klären sehr transparent und welche daten
wir bitten und wozu wir sie nutzen
wollen also ohne postleitzahl ist quasi
die app nicht sehr sinnvoll weil wir
einfach etwas brauchen das ist ja der
punkt der für unser institut zu einer
grosse wichtigkeit spielt wir wollen ja
das geschehen immer so
wirklich einschätzen können um zu sehen
wie die maßnahmen wirken natürlich die
krankheitslast wieder verändert
vielleicht wenn die maßnahmen gelockert
werden und das ist ein kleiner baustein
der uns quasi neben vielen anderen
baustellen die wir haben hier eine
verbesserung schafft das das ist
eigentlich das was ich zu
für diese app sagen kann was man dann
das passt ja auch zur frage vorher von
ihnen aber von zentiva nie natürlich
sehr mit diesem postleitzahlen bezog das
sind ist ja ne app die auch auf daten
die sozusagen am körper gemessen werden
dazu greift aber nicht personenbezogene
postleitzahl bezogen sozusagen serie das
in einer bestimmten region sich eine
bestimmte entwicklung abzeichnet dann
würde man natürlich mit den behörden vor
ort darüber reden ob und welche
maßnahmen notwendig sind um darauf zu
reagieren das ist ja der sinn der sache
möglichst frühzeitig ansteckung
situation cluster zu erkennen und
möglichst frühzeitig eben eine dynamik
erst gar nicht wieder entstehen zu
lassen die andere es wichtig zu
unterscheiden nichts andere app nach der
sicher auch gefragt haben ist die wo es
um die kontakte nach verfolgung geht
auch da ist es wichtig dass das
natürlich sowohl was den datenschutz
angeht mit dem
bundesdatenschutzbeauftragten wie was
die sicherheit angeht auch mit dem bse
natürlich abgestimmt werden muss und
auch von denen geprüft sein muss und mit
sozusagen haken versehen sein muss für
eine mögliche umsetzung auch das robert
koch institut wird ja aus
epidemiologischer sicht entsprechend das
ganze zu bewerten haben
aber ich habe ja gerade schon gesagt ein
rezept mit einem solchen virus das so
infektiös ist weil eben im rachenraum
die viren sind so ansteckend ist das
neue ist wo wir im moment eben auch
keine grund immunität haben in der
bevölkerung ist einfach eine schnelle
kontakt nachverfolgung das ist eines der
entscheidenden schlüssel wenn ich sogar
der entscheidende schlüssel und sie kann
man händisch machen so wie das die
gesundheitsbehörden heute eben machen
abfragen telefonieren das kostet viel
zeit und ressourcen und ist er fordert
übrigens ich weiß nicht ob sie das
könnten ich musste lange überlegen noch
zu wissen wie man die letzten zwölf tage
eineinhalb meter nahe war für längere
zeit also es muss auch ein gutes
erinnerungsvermögen
noch dazu kommen bei demjenigen der
haben mehr infos geben muss darüber
welche kontakte hatte und da sind die
frage ob und ich bin der festen
überzeugung dass eine digitale anwendung
unterstützung eine app auf dem handy als
freiwilliges angebot so ist es ja auch
entwickelt und angelegt tatsächlich
dabei helfen und unterstützen kann
dabei gilt aber natürlich eins wenn das
gelingt das umzusetzen und das
entsprechend auch datenschutz so
datensicherheits mäßig den anforderungen
das system genüge trägt das dann auch
hinreichend viele mitmachen müssen so
wie jetzt schon 160000
dankenswerterweise bei der einen app mit
machen bräuchte man bei der app noch
deutlich mehr
die mitmachen damit tatsächlich einen
unterschied machen kann
aber diese app wie sie schon gesagt
haben ist ja noch in der entwicklung die
noch eine nachfrage
was ist die frage jetzt dazu eine befund
ein befund also die die aussage dass die
ich habe sogar eine stellungnahme vom
bundesdatenschutzbeauftragten sie in zu
der daten spende app die mir glaube ich
in der letzten woche zugestellt wurde
und nun das nur dazu
diese fragen werden wir alle klären und
natürlich ist uns vollkommen bewusst
dass wir das sehr sehr gut kommunizieren
müssen das werden wir auch so
transparent wie möglich machen
keine sorge diese app ist in oder gerät
momentan noch gar nicht von der
entwicklung einer app schon den ganzen
technischen vorgang der noch in einer
entwicklung ist den wir noch intensiver
durchleuchten werden gar keine frage die
zahl der infizierten der bundespolizei
und derjenigen die unter quarantäne sind
können problemlos bei der bundespolizei
vielen dank eine bitte noch eine
nachricht an die kollegen draußen bitte
schicken sie ihre fragen nicht doppelt
und dreifach das erhöht überhaupt nicht
die übersichtlichkeit auf meinem
bildschirm und vor allen dingen nicht in
dem moment wo ich sie gerade vorlese
wenn sie
dann nochmal kommt dann geißler
überhaupt nicht mehr lesen frau braun
ist die nächste also ich hoffe nicht
dass die die pathologen auf teufel komm
raus obduzieren möchten aber obduktion
sind sehr wichtig das habe ich ja auch
schon mehrfach betont
es herrscht offensichtlich ein gerücht
dass wir optionen nicht wünschen oder
davon abraten das gegenteil ist
natürlich der fall
wir brauchen einfach informationen
darüber woran die menschen verstorben
sind daraus lernen wir sehr viel auch
wenn es natürlich gerade um bei ärzten
darum geht therapeutika einzusetzen und
ich hatte das auch schon mal gesagt aber
für uns ist vor allem interessant wenn
junge menschen gesunde menschen an
dieser krankheit versterben was dann der
der mechanismus ist woran sie
verstorbene da ist wirklich wichtig für
das verständnis der krankheit aber eben
auch dafür dass man dann bestimmte
therapeutische ansätze gezielt auf
fahren können ich halte gar nichts von
diesem vermeintlichen das ist ja
manchmal den überschriften betonte motto
wirtschaft und oder wirtschaft oder
gesundheit wirtschaft gegen gesundheit
was auch immer es ja gerade auch schon
dargestellt wurden auch die maßnahmen
die ergriffen werden machen ja was mit
der gesundheit wenn menschen in
kurzarbeit sind gehen müssen sich
gedanken machen über die zukunft ihres
ihres jobs wenn unklar ist wie die
perspektive ist wenn man sich gerade
selbstständig gemacht hat in der
gastronomie und auf einmal wird an das
restaurant geschlossen
das macht ihr alles was mit den menschen
und vermutlich keine probleme noch mehr
zu
sagen auch mit der gesundheit zumindest
bei nicht wenigen und dessen kann man ja
nicht einfach sagen es geht um die
wirtschaft das ist ja nix anonymous sind
wir alle jeden tag teil dieser
wirtschaft und deswegen müssen wir eben
insgesamt schauen welche folgen hat was
und das ja in dieser öffentlichen
debatte die vorhin angesprochen wurde
natürlich auch miteinander in abwägung
bringen am ende geht es doch um das
richtige verhältnis der richtige balance
von gesundheitsschutz in dieser epidemie
öffentlichen leben wirtschaftlichen
lebens sozialen leben die die richtige
balance zu finden und es ging aber vor
allem mitte märz erstmal darum die diese
dynamik abzubremsen
wir sind in eine phase kommen von einer
sehr starken dynamik getriggert durch
den winterurlaub zu rückreiseverkehr
insbesondere aus österreich schweiz
norditalien das ist gilt phänomen ist ja
schon hinreichend beschrieben und
gleichzeitig eben der situation die wir
rundum heinsberg hatten
und beides hat sehr stark auf einmal in
eine ausbruchs dynamik geführt und die
zu beenden das war jetzt so fördert mal
die aufgabe um nimmt nicht in
situationen hinein zu kommen wie wir sie
in anderen wie sie andere länder erleben
und durchleiden mussten und der teil ist
jetzt für diese erster linie jedenfalls
bis hierhin bis hierhin gelungen ich
will übrigens auch eines sagen die
kurzarbeit bei vw oder porsche haben
nicht wie er hat nicht die politik
entschieden sondern es sind dinge die
auch zusammenhängen mit fragen wenn auf
einmal bestimmte teile nicht mehr
zugeliefert werden können weil die
internationalen lieferketten in probleme
geraten sind wenn absatzmärkte nicht
mehr da sind wenn autos nicht mehr
verkauft werden können muss irgendwann
kann kann sie nicht immer mehr
produzieren also ist ja nicht nur eine
frage was es in deutschland gerade die
situation für die frage wie es der
wirtschaft geht
das hängt ja auch mit ganz anderen auch
europäischen internationalen
zusammenhängen zusammen und deswegen
finde ich dieses manchmal etwas unter
komplexe bild wirtschaft gegen
gesundheit da nicht besonders hilfreich
in der debatte
es gibt mitarbeiter
[Musik]
also zum ersten haben wir bis heute
keine völlige abriegelung in deutschland
gemacht um das auch mal zu sagen wir
haben maßnahmen ergriffen die im
öffentlichen leben für viele eine
einschränkung sind ja wir haben nicht
nicht irgendwie was ganze land völlig
abgeriegelt und alles lahmgelegt und
keiner darf mehr auf die straße treten
das ist ein qualitativer unterschied zu
dem was sie gerade in der fragestellung
beschrieben haben darauf lege ich schon
schon wert gleichwohl haben wir
natürlich eine dynamik gerade in der
zweiten märzhälfte miteinander erlebt
sowohl in den infektionsquellen als auch
eben in den daraus folgenden maßnahmen
die ergriffen worden sind
das steht ja außer frage und dass wir
natürlich auch immer als der lage und
den erkenntnissen und der dynamik
anpassen müssen die entscheidung steht
auch außer frage also wenn ich manchmal
heute lese wer immer schon was waren
alles gewusst hat dann bin ich neidisch
moment mal bitte zwölf tage sind in
dieser zeit erstens eine lange zeit und
zweitens lege ich noch mal wert darauf
dass auch die kontakt beschränkungen die
es in bestimmten bundesländern in
deutschland gibt ein qualitativer
unterschied sind zu dem szenario dass
sie in ihrer ersten frage beschrieben
haben herr professor li na ja also ich
habe zwei gute nachrichten für sie der
eine nachricht ist die ich würde sehr
gut von der politik unterstützt und die
zweite nachricht das was wir in an
unterstützung bekommen ist kein tropfen
auf den heißen stein sondern ein schöner
warmer regen
ich habe noch eine frage da geht es auch
im weitesten sinne um unterstützung für
sie uns der herr kollege jettka vom zdf
fragt wie viele mitarbeiter sich bei
ihnen also im robert-koch-institut um
social media kümmern
und warum sie nicht bei twitter
antworten auf nutzerfragen und warum
begegnen sie falschmeldungen nicht von
sich aus viel aktiver tja also bei uns
bewegen sich nicht viele menschen auf
sozialen medien das ist tatsächlich wahr
wir sind ja eine eine fachbehörde
einfach institution die sich an
wissenschaftler und wissenschaftlerinnen
und dann an das fachpersonal wendet von
unserem gesetzlichen auftrag her und
warum ich mich nicht auf twitter äußern
das ist nicht mal mit je ich bin nicht
gut auf twitter dann lass ich lieber
vielleicht daran sind für die
bundespressekonferenz ist uns das auch
viel lieber wenn sie sich hier ich will
aber vielleicht nach freunden zu vielen
vw falls auch zu der feurigen frage das
robert-koch-institut dass eine behörde
des bundesministeriums für gesundheit
und die arbeiten und aktivitäten die wir
auf in den sozialen medien
auch entfalten entwickeln um zu
informieren über krone über mögliche
verhaltensweisen die wir empfehlen
unter dem hashtag wir bleiben zu hause
an sozialen medien kampagnen glaube ich
dass wir alles in allem rund um das
frage corona was kann man wissen darüber
wie geht's kann man sich verhalten
welche empfehlungen gibt es seitens der
bundesregierung des bundesministeriums
für gesundheit sehr umfänglich
informieren und wir freuen uns über
jeden der uns in den sozialen medien
folgt ministerin er vielleicht kann
nicht dazu ergänzen
auch das bundesfamilienministerium hat
umfangreiche informationen für familien
wir haben ja unser familienportal de
auch das info tour familie für alle
digitalen familienleistungen und wir
informieren
auch mit gesonderten informationen auch
zum thema häusliche gewalt auf der
homepage www stärker als gewalt punkt.de
wir haben auch einen sehr guten zugriffe
normalerweise hunderttausend menschen in
der woche die unsere angebote sich anton
das hat sich verzehnfacht in den letzten
tagen über eine million eltern familien
senioren und senioren junge menschen die
diese angebote in anspruch nehmen und
für uns ist jetzt wichtig dass wir eben
auch ein gegenpol setzen zu fake news
und dann zu sagen wir haben seriöse
informationen
wir bereiten die jeden tag neu auf und
ich denke dass das ist auch das signal
seitens der bundesregierung dass wir
versuchen auf allen auf social media
kanälen mit den dingen die jetzt
passieren auch präsent zu sein
da gibt es das nächste mal
steckt der verein drucker
also zunächst mal zu der zahl eher 0 die
sie ansprechen
die steht zurzeit nach den berechnungen
die wir anstrengen bei 1,2
das heißt also sie ist nicht und dann
eins gegangen
sie schwankt nach wie vor fast täglich
wir berechnen 7 auf einen zeitraum von
vier tagen in einem bestimmten
zeitabschnitt die frage der genesenen es
ist klar je mehr menschen infiziert
werden desto größer ist natürlich auch
dann die anzahl derjenigen die chinesen
dass das ergibt sich ja glaube ich
daraus hatten sie in die dritte frage
die sie gestellt haben
[Musik]
wenn es wenden wenn es wenn es unter 1
ginge dann würde das irgendwann
eintreten bislang sind aber leider nicht
bei unter 1 und ich weiß was wirklich
wichtiges zu verstehen
das ist ja eine pandemie und die
zeichnet sich dadurch aus dass wir eben
in der bevölkerung keinen grund
immunität haben ein neues virus haben
und die biologischen hintergründe sind
die das 60 bis 70 prozent der menschen
infiziert sein müssen damit eine
pandemie zum stoppen kommt falls wir
keinen impfstoff haben solange wir
keinen impfstoff haben das heißt also
wir reden in von wellen von einzelnen
wellen und diese erste welle die erleben
wir ja gerade die flaut ab wir hatten
ein eher 0 das deutlich höher war und
sie flott aber deshalb ab weil wir eben
diese regeln eingeführt haben und vor
allen dingen das abstandhalten gut
hinbekommen haben dass wir uns alle
daran gehalten haben aber wir werden
sehen wie sich das ändert wenn bestimmte
maßnahmen wieder gelockert werden ich
kann keine zeiträume dazu nennen das
weiß niemand und wir können es nur
messen und wir haben zwei entscheidende
dinge geschafft in den letzten wochen
wir haben die kapazitäten im
gesundheitswesen oder auch im
öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst steigern
wir test kapazitäten das ist in
deutschland wirklich vorhand gelungen
das gibt uns mehr raum um menschen zu
behandeln und es gibt es auch mehr kraft
um infektions ausbrüche wieder
nachzugehen also das heißt wenn wir
ausbrüche haben dass wir schnell
unterbrechen
das sind zwei wesentliche erfolge und
wir hoffen halt dass wir damit die
kommenden ausbrüche die kommen werden
weil das virus nach wie vor im land ist
dass wir ihnen kontrollieren können das
habe ich noch eine frage von nick
leifert vom zdf der fragt nach den
influenza infektionszahlen sind gleich
und auch den toten ob sie uns dazu etwas
sagen können ja wir haben die
influenzawelle die ist überstanden wir
haben also auch die maßnahmen die ja
durchgeführt wurden die haben auch dazu
geführt dass die influenzawelle etwas
früher nach unserer einschätzung früher
aufhörte wir wissen dass schulschließung
gerade für den fans eine große rolle
spielt die zahlen für den trends habe
ich nicht im kopf
moment da für die jetzige influenzawelle
habe ich nicht im kopf aber vielen dank
und die frau kollegen dankbar formen der
berliner zeitung fragt sie ein minister
sparen
wie viele von den f2 und f3 masken im
märz und im april importiert worden sind
mir genügt die schlichte zahl schreibt
sie fehler seitens des bundes oder
generell wie viele generell nach
deutschen ist die bundesrepublik
generell nach deutschland importiert und
so werden sie sind kann ich nicht sagen
weil es ja auch andere beschaffer ergibt
aus dem kopf kann ich eben sagen dass es
in den zwei wochen vor dieser woche 40
millionen zusammen 135 p2 und op masken
waren auch ein anteil der 5 p 3 aber ich
werde es der frau kollegin gerne als
detaillierte zahlen übersicht übergeben
und in dieser woche eben nochmal 40
millionen nur in dieser einen woche
seitens der bundesbeschaffung dass wir
eben eine deutlich stärkere dynamik da
drin haben seit zwei wochen den ansatz
wählen den ich vorhin dargestellt habe
auch in kooperation mit anderen
unternehmen wir haben gestern zu ende
erfolg gestern zu ende gehen gehabt eine
ausschreibung für den
produktionsstandort deutschland auch
eine erste kleinere das ist ja das was
jetzt auch das
bundeswirtschaftsministerium stärker
auch mit unserer beteiligung aber eben
wir beschaffen
dort wird jetzt als produktionsstandort
deutschland auch gestärkt wo wir überall
weit über 100 angebote hatten wo wir
jetzt in der nächsten woche auch werden
zu schlagen können sozusagen die
angebote wo dann auch produktion in
deutschland ab mitte des jahres in den
bereichen dadurch an gereizt wird und
steigen kann und wir hatten ein
vergabeverfahren das auch sehr stark
benutzt worden ist mit angeboten das
auch gestern endete ein so genanntes
open house tenderverfahren auch dort gab
es sehr grossvolumige angebote aber wir
haben halt auch in der vergangenheit mit
großvolumigen angeboten die erfahrung
gemacht dass ich nicht alle davon
erfüllen
die genauen zahlen würden wir gerne der
frau kollegin dann nochmal nachliefern
dann gibt's die auf die maske genau
jetzt gehts hier vorne weiter können sie
netterweise mikrofon nehmen dann
verstehen sie auch etwas
jetzt geht es in die details des
kaufprozesses der markt ist aber
tatsächlich im moment ein sehr
ungewöhnlicher wegen der starken
nachfrage international
bei allen diskussionen die es gibt rund
um die ausrüstung und vorhaltung mit
medizinischer schutzausrüstung muss man
ja sehen und zur kenntnis nehmen dass im
grunde kein land auf der welt
ausreichend schutzausrüstung hatte und
alle sich gerade darum bemühen
entsprechend eben zu kaufen
das führt zu der entsprechenden
situation auf dem markt die an
bestimmten stellen auch vorkasse wie sie
es nennen notwendig macht vor allem aber
auch unser ziel ist in längerfristige
beziehung vertragsbeziehungen zu kommen
auch mit produzenten in asien
weil wir auch viel zwischenhändler sehen
und zwischenhandel ist auch wichtig im
wirtschaftsleben kostet aber meistens
viel aufschlag und auch den teil
versuchen wir versuchen wir weniger
abhängig von zu werden und dabei helfen
natürlich die kooperation mit
unternehmen die es übrigens zum
selbstkostenpreis machen
damit unternehmen die auf deutschen
unternehmen die ihm sagen wer würde ich
jetzt auch patriotisch mithelfen dass
wir für diejenigen geben
gesundheitswesen jeden tag tätig sind
ausreichend schutzausrüstung haben also
der der teil die kontakte dadurch helfen
und wir begleiten das natürlich auch
dann in politischen gesprächen
an verschiedenen stellen auch wie auch
an uns wünsche gerichtet werden um das
auch zu sagen natürlich bekommen wir ja
auch anfragen von anderen ländern ob es
bereiche gibt wo wir stark sind in denen
wir helfen können und unterstützen
können
jetzt geht es bei ihnen weiter
[Musik]
und das möglichst kollegin können sie
sich ein bisschen kürzer fassen aber
dann hatte ich ja darum gebeten dass wir
hier gucken nimmt aber nicht so lange
also zum ersten wundere ich mich jetzt
etwas darüber dass so getan wird
scheinbar von einigen die sich scheinbar
zitieren dass es keine kriterien gebe
über die diskutiert wird wir haben
gerade hier noch über kriterien
gesprochen und messparameter für die
frage wie die geologische lage ist und
was aus unserer sicht für parameter
dabei zu berücksichtigen sind ich habe
mehr fahrt noch gestern in einer
pressekonferenz darauf hingewiesen dass
ein kriterium ohne zweifel die frage ist
was ist für eine gesellschaft
erleichtert verzichte und schwerer
verzichtbar für den einzelnen für die
gesellschaft arbeiten gehen
lebensunterhalt verdienen da kann man
schwerer darauf verzichten als auf die
party um smart auf den punkt zu bringen
und gleichzeitig eben und das ist dann
miteinander zu koppeln
in der frage was ist mit welchem risiko
verbunden dass infektionen entstehen
dass infektion aussprechen wenn es
gelingt in einer produktionshalle durch
abstands und hygieneregeln das
infektionsrisiko zu minimieren
es ist leichter in eine normalität von
produktions zurückzukehren als wenn auf
einmal so eine party mit zwei meter
abstand ist wahrscheinlich keine party
im eigentlichen sinne mehr das wird sich
dort nicht mehr so umsetzen lassen
das sind alles kriterien habe ich aber
den eindruck die jetzt auch schon seit
längerem in der diskussion
richtigerweise natürlich sind jetzt mal
auch aus gesundheitspolitischer sicht
übrigens zum verfassungsrechtlichen
frage ich habe mal gesagt es kann sein
dass wir in eine zeit kommen wo wir die
älteren bitten müssen im sinne von
eigenverantwortung ein stück auch
weiterhin kontakte zu reduzieren
jetzt habe ich gelesen dass die bitte an
ältere schon verfassungswidrig ist
aber im sinne von eigenverantwortung zu
sagen es gibt bestimmte risiken für
bestimmte gruppen einfach weil das virus
ist wie es ist das hat sich ja keine
ausgedacht dieses virus ist halt leider
mit einem besonderen risiko versehen
wenn ich eben in einer bestimmten
gesundheitlichen verfassung bin und oder
das geht ja auch miteinander einher in
einer bestimmten altersgruppe und
deswegen zu sagen wir klären darüber auf
für informieren darüber wir wollen diese
bevölkerungsgruppen schützen und dazu
gehört aber eben auch sie zu informieren
und bestimmte
haltens weisen an zu empfehlen finde ich
etwas sehr vorausschauendes vernünftiges
an dieser stelle und kann mich über
manche begriffe die dazu in der letzten
tagen in der öffentlichen debatte
gefallen sind trade off ist kein begriff
den weiß jetzt nicht mehr den gemacht
hat ihnen jemand
ich habe ihn jedenfalls nicht gemacht
was ich gesagt habe ist dass wenn wir
diese sehr starken grundrechts
einschränkungen die wir haben bei diesen
maßnahmen gewerbefreiheit in teilen
religionsfreiheit versammlungsfreiheit
das werden wir dort schrittweise wieder
herauswollen das habe ich ja schon drei
mal auch ja gesagt eine grundbedingung
ist also dass wir in der lage sind sehr
schnell kontakte nachzuvollziehen
nachzuverfolgen und die frage es mit
welchen instrumenten und werkzeugen geht
das am besten und auch dazu habe ich den
eindruck dass die gesellschaftliche
debatte sowohl als gesellschaftlicher
als rechtliche als ethische debatte im
vollen gang ist und ich finde das gut
wir sind schon über der zeit die wir
vereinbart hatten
ich habe noch eine frage von herrn
constant kreativ man die noch ich sehe
nutzen immer und an die kollegin riesa
die fragt ob die heilmittelerbringer
auch unter den schutzschirm fallen kann
ich auf die regierungs pressekonferenz
von gestern verweisen da war die antwort
ja aber es sei denn sie wollen
die frage war wann wieder runterkommen
gestern wurde aber gesagt die sein da
bereits darunter
[Musik]
also die verdopplung rate ist eine zahl
die ging ja nur während dieser
logarithmischen oder exponentiellen
wachstumsphase da ging es um die
verdopplung
das hängt aber davon ab welchen zeitraum
sie betrachten also sie können die
verschiedene zeiträume nehmen das heißt
also wenn sie die reihen meldezahlen
nehmen dann können sie je nachdem wie
die steigerung der kurve ist können sie
die verdopplung zahlen auf 7 tage
rechnen auf zehn tage je nachdem wie sie
es möchten also das heißt jeder kann das
rechnet wer möchte dass eine größe die
für uns nie so richtig relevant war was
glaube ich wichtiges zu verstehen
es gibt keine ware zahlen ja ganz genau
wer sie sagen es gibt eben dunkelziffern
es gibt annahmen und es gibt bestimmte
mathematische modelle und wir werden
auch gerade glaube ich heute sogar
profitieren wir noch mal einen artikel
um das genau zu erklären wie wir diese
zahlen berechnen weil es auch andere
kollegen gibt und es gibt verschiedene
mathematische modelle die auch zu
anderen etwas anderen ergebnissen kommen
dort finden sie die die mathematischen
hintergründe dazu wichtig ist für uns
dass wir ein modell berechnen dass wir
konsequent dieses einem modell berechnet
dann für unsere einschätzungen nehmen es
gibt andere wissenschaftler die anderen
modelle nehmen und sie können halt immer
sicher davon sein dass wir diese andere
modelle natürlich auch im auge haben ja
das ist wichtig es gibt keine wahre zahl
weil es eine dunkelziffer gibt wird es
eine bestimmte ungenauigkeit will auch
weil es einfach zu viele dinge gibt die
wir noch nicht wissen über das virus
sind immer nur ausgerechnet modellierte
zahlen und das ist ist es wichtig für
die leute zu unter zu unterscheiden auch
wenn wenn ich weiß dass alle menschen
sich jemand den zahlen sehr stark
ausrichten
aber das sind alles zahlen die eine
bestimmte wahrheit wieder spielen aber
niemals die hundertprozentige wahrheit
immer mit einer gewissen unsicherheit
verbunden sind und deswegen finde ich
ein hinweis noch wichtig auch zu der
frage die vorgestellt wurde
es gibt nicht den einen wissenschaftlich
parameter der dann zur entscheidung
geführt und den finde ich kann es in
einer freiheitlichen demokratie auch
nicht geben so am ende trägt politik die
verantwortung in dem wissen um dinge und
dem was wissenschaftlich grund gelegt
werden kann um zusammenhänge in
verschiedene bereiche hinein
aber am ende muss politik entscheiden da
für sie gewählt in der repräsentativen
demokratie und wir können am ende immer
auf bestmöglicher wissensbasis
entscheiden
auch in dem wissen wo wissensbasis auch
unzulänglichkeiten hat aber am ende gibt
es nicht so ein parameter wo man sagen
kann und wenn a eintritt dann folgt
daraus automatisch in der politischen
entscheidung und ich weiß auch nicht ob
so ein ansatz vor allem mit all dem was
wir zur frage von information und ihrem
ihren entwicklungsbedarf auch sehen ob
das richtig wäre
wir entscheiden wer wissens geleitet und
wenn ich mich auf der welt umschauen
fahren wir damit mit diesem westens
geleiteten ansatz im unterschied zu
anderen ansätzen die ich auf der welt so
sehe ziemlich gut aber am ende
entscheide politik finde ich schon noch
wichtig sind am ende dieser
pressekonferenz vielen dank dass sie zu
uns gekommen sind in die
bundespressekonferenz vielen dank gehabt
haben
ich wünsche uns ein poster